my name is James Morton and I'm the head
of nutrition for Team Sky I think the
traditional belief in sport nutrition
has been it's all about carbohydrate for
endurance athletes but actually what we
now know from research is that in many
occasions protein is just as important
as carbohydrate especially in an event
like a Grand Tour because when you're
under fueling which may be sometimes you
could do then effectively you start to
lose lean muscle mass so when it comes
to fluid intake for Team Sky we have
three different types of fluids that we
use and actually believe it or not the
first bottle on our bike is always a
protein drink and the reason why we do
that is because the last time their
riders would have had some protein would
have been their breakfast and the next
time they'll have some protein will be
the recovery meal so we could go six
seven eight hours without any protein so
what we always to write in bottle one is
make sure we get enough protein and that
first drink the second bottle is usually
a mixture of carbohydrate or might be
plain water but over the course and
duration of that stage the riders will
alternate between carbohydrate drinks or
water whatever they prefer or the
electrolyte drinks like the go hydro
capsules and when it comes to actual
fluid intake it really depends on the
environmental temperature sometimes I've
seen a liter per hour sometimes I've
seen as little as 250 300 mils per hour
and it's very rider specific and when
I've done all of the dietary analysis
and I've looked through the what the
riders in see it's probably around two
and a half grams per kilo of protein
actually and what we tend to find
actually is that when we increase that
protein intake to ruin that among
people's where it maintains the seam and
when we don't people tend to lose weight
and performance suffers so when it comes
to protein before sleep as many of us
know I know it's a real important time
and lots of research is now showing us
that consuming protein right before bed
can help me and that protein balance
when you sleep and the best source of
protein fill out then is milk protein
because of course that's a mixture of
casein that slow digesting protein and
of course whey protein which isn't worth
the rapid release type protein and the
overnight protein the science and sport
do is perfect for us as you know a lot
of artery and inner eyes are based on
this concept of high carbohydrate versus
let's call it smart car behaves
and we do that to try and maximize the
tree in a response but one of the
pitfalls when you tree in a lower
reduced carbohydrate state is the muscle
protein oxidation increases so the sis
way 24 us is one of the most exciting
products for 2016 Oxley
and thankfully this product has now came
along which is a real easy convenient
product that the riders can take out
with them on those long rides and we
just got a nice head of 20 grams of
protein